so dear prime minister
a very warm welcome
it's a pleasure to meet you finally in
person
the european commission and myself we
are very glad to have you as a partner
these are challenging times
and as standing united we are much
stronger
we have to master several crises we have
to master the climate crisis
we are
at the
um europe's recovery
for from covet 19 we have to master
the economic
recovery again and of course there is
the very volatile backdrop of the russia
ukraine crisis we see at the moment so
it is good to count on your friendship
your dedication to our common european
priorities
and of course i'm very much looking
forward to the czech presidency in the
second half of this year
um this will be a very important part of
the discussions we will have together
now
but we will also of course today address
the situation in ukraine
we will have discussions with all eu
leaders all 27 in a few hours to further
coordinate our positions
diplomacy has not yet spoken its last
word
that is good
and we have still hope that peace will
prevail
and i commend the efforts of many eu
leaders who have engaged with both
parties seeking to find a diplomatic
solution
now we hear claims from russia about
pulling back troops
but we have not seen any signs so far of
de-escalation on the ground
to the contrary we see that the build-up
continues
therefore now we need deeds to trust the
words we have heard
we will not let our guard down
we will stay vigilant and united
over the past days i had intensive
contact with many partners both on our
response to any aggression by russia
and on our preparedness
we are ready we hope for the best but we
are prepared for the worst
and prime minister this will be all the
topics we will discuss together
so again a very warm welcome
thank you very much madam president
ladies and gentlemen it's my first visit
here in brussels in position of
czech prime minister
i'm very pleased to meet
madam president
we spoke together in the last weeks of
course but via phone and
i think mythic in person is completely
different it's it's different level is
is better and i look forward to our
meeting i am coming to inform madam
president about preparation for the
czech presidency of
council of european union that starts in
july this year
i think it's also a good opportunity to
discuss to discuss uh priorities of
czech presidency
and and of course some important issues
for the czech republic such as
energy policy results of taxonomy
situation of ukraine on ukraine russian
border and european security
and
i hope i am sure
it's a start for cooperative partnership
between european commission and czech
government
and i look forward to our discussion
thank you very much
please